I have a tremendous amount of love and
compassion for everyone else and you're
never going to have the perfect set of
circumstances to be able to do it you
look so uncomfortable right now she's
great and she's really funny and nice
and sweet and she's a great improviser
so your journey today we're going to
learn from actress and singer and
Hathaway and my take under top ten goals
and success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always as you're watching if you hear
something that president's with you
please leave it in the comments below
but folks around us or other people can
be inspired by enterprise as well and
also when you write it down as much more
likely to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
yeah I had I gotten out of the habit of
googling myself because that's just a
bad idea he ever do that and I was
trying to come up with a my friends and
I had an idea for Funny or Die and we
wanted to like do something on celebrity
pregnancy rumors - we just googled
pregnancy rumors and then the story came
up and what was the story the story the
title of it was why does everybody hate
Anne Hathaway so I think and you know I
know really okay no no it has a happy
ending I thought life continues but I
know what that feels like and I think
when people write things like that or
say things like that it is cyberbullying
and so how did you deal with all that
well I listened at first and that I
couldn't help it you know you and you
try to shut it off and and I couldn't
and then I realized why I couldn't was I
hadn't learned to love myself yet I
hadn't gotten there and if you don't
love yourself when someone else says
horrible things to you a part of he's
always gonna believe them yep and I so
then it was like okay I don't want to
believe these people I don't want to
agree with them on any level I want to
and I I would have figure out who I am I
want to learn Who I am and I don't want
to feel like I'm I'm fragile every time
I leave the house because I'm so
dependent on what other people think
about me so I just took a step back and
as Matthew would say my thing kind of my
co-star in the interest I would say I
just kept living and it's been a really
cool journey and I feel like I've
arrived in a place where you know maybe
not every minute of every day but way
more than I used to I have a tremendous
amount of love and compassion for
everyone else and best of all I have it
for myself which I never enjoyed before
I've used playback in films before and
my mind has a tendency to wander I think
it would have required a different
amount of concentration I also think
that it would have become frustrating to
be locked into a performance one of the
things that was great about the live
singing was that it allowed for multi
camera shooting which is my personal
favorite way to work where
you don't have to worry later on in the
day okay what did I do this morning go
back in time what if you find a new
truth in the scene you can follow it
because the take is being shot in its
entirety from all angles so there's
choices in the editing room later on I
find that that lets me relax and let go
and the last time that I it was a that I
shot that way was Rachel Getting Married
so it was a nice return to to that
format for me and the the one takes
scene that he does for I dreamed a dream
did how many times did you do that and
you remember in any of those takes
thinking this has got to be the one this
has got to be the one he's going to use
you know I was trying not to think when
I was doing it but but the one that is
in the film when I got to the end of it
I just thought I don't think I can do
better than that I'd like to try but um
but if it's that one I can look I can I
can live with that I can go home and
hang my and keep my head held high so
talking about to me after that one was
the fourth take and he said I'm very
happy and I said I I don't want to keep
going and so he shot for another eight
hours and then at the end of that is
eight hours we looked at each other and
said it was that one that we shot in the
morning dear but it was good to hook on
that full journey so that I know that
that literally even though I I desired
to do better that actually was my best I
guess in March or April of 2011 that
there was going to be a film version of
the musical Amos and Hugh Jackman was
probably going to be in it and I just
said oh my gosh
I'll play anybody please just let me
audition which I did a few months later
and then got the part of my that that
did you know like from before that it
was gonna be like life singing and
because that's a big challenge of it I
think um Tom still making up his mind
about it you know whether how exactly it
was going to be done how much of it was
going to be live he knew he wanted the
show to be sung through but didn't know
if we would be dropping certain lines
here and there but I thought it was a
great idea I thought it was such a cool
challenge to to try to do that when it's
I don't think I've there's been a couple
movies that were sung through the entire
time but not one made recently so I
don't know it seemed like it would be
pretty cool if we were able to pull it
off a lot of people wanted to know if
I'm like my character
okay idly I mean I like my character so
I hope that I am I mean I think she's
feisty and sweet and big-hearted and
tough and maybe like me like when the
movie started she kind of is a little
angry and has a little bit of a chip on
her shoulder against the world and I
think when I started ryeo-won I was in
that place and now she's married and
quite happy and I'm in that place too so
maybe there's a little parallel there
Aiko I wasn't unhappy were having a chip
on her shoulder you always seemed very
sweet oh thank you I mean I try I try to
be polite to everybody but now now that
feeling actually runs quite deep as
before I think I might have been just
faking it okay not faking it you know
but not wanting to be disrespectful the
people that came in but yeah I think I
think I think we all have anger inside
of us and you've no good anyway I'm this
well let me lay down on the couch we'll
have a therapy session it'll be fine
we'll just to hear because the ATIS
actresses you do sort of have that
veneer of just glossy wonderfulness it's
quite nice too you get angry yeah of
course of course and then part of the
joy of life is learning how to like
admit that say that out loud and then
learn to not be angry with it you know
just kind of yes so anyways so I feel
like like my character I'm letting
happiness in a lot more and I'm kind of
living my life from that place so I just
did a play it was a one-woman show and I
just had a lot of stuff just kind of
hitting me in my personal life and I
didn't think I could go on that just
like something really hard had happened
that day
and I never I mean you know me III could
never imagine missing a performance but
I really didn't think I could go on that
day and I called my boss at the theater
and he just said it you got to do it you
gotta do it you got to dig down deep you
have an understudy did you know no I
didn't have an understand the only one
in the show so and he said you know you
just go on stage and you just got a
trust it's gonna be there you're gonna
find it and there was this moment on I
remember where I I like didn't go up on
a line but the line just wouldn't come
out and I had to handle it in the moment
and I needed a break from the audience
and I just kind of curled up into a ball
on stage
and took a breath and stood up and I
thought that maybe I just ruined the
show but they were totally with it and
it occurred to me they didn't know that
this was an unusual show and yeah it was
a way more raw performance than I had
been giving but it was it worked and I
got it and a huge audience reaction that
night so I guess the thing that I
learned is like it's not really about
you it's not really about what you think
and and and and you're never going to
have the perfect set of circumstances to
be able to do it you just gotta accept
it for what it is go with it I'm kind of
type-a so I always add a little bit of a
perfectionist so I will always want to
get it right and it's you know as
opposed to a day away my job in acting
there's no way to get it right there's
no way to be like there's no clear you
know absolute way to do things you just
kind of go with what you're feeling and
hope that it works out you know that's
that it's the best that that could have
been chosen but I think I'm a very lucky
actress and I think that I'm one thing I
can get myself a compliment about is I
think I'm a good student mm-hmm and I'm
I'm learning I'm certainly not I've done
good things but I don't think I could
describe myself yet it's like a good
actress I just think that I'm someone
who is always open to learning and I and
I think that's that that's something I'm
very proud of it myself
trust truck you know what if I could go
back and talk to myself I had really
great people in my life and I'm not
someone that trusts easily and I could
have learned a lot if I'd opened myself
up to trusting people more readily which
is a very scary thing to do but now you
know God Here I am over a dozen years
later and I do trust those people in my
life has opened up beautifully this is a
question that really I shouldn't ask
well what's something they wrote this
what's something you learned from
working with me you could learn nothing
well I didn't learn nothing that's for
sure I mean I don't want to embarrass
you but I had my like antenna up the
entire time we were working together I'm
not sure if you're aware of this you're
a legend and so it would be foolish not
to observe you just to learn how you
know the best does it and the thing that
just blew me away and what I learned was
you're so relaxed on set and you're so
humble about everything it's not about
any of the nonsense any of the drama not
the fact it's not about oh you brought
zero drama to the set any day and I
didn't it was just a great delight to
discover that someone who is as
well-known and well-respected and
legendary as you could have no ego great
pride in your work and and great level
of attention and care with your
character and for the work that we were
doing but no ego and I thought that was
that would be refreshing in anyone but
the fact that it was you made it kind of
priceless you look so uncomfortable
right no sorry
I really enjoyed answering that my
favorite lesson I ever had was for my
teacher Seth Irish at the Barrow group
and he he had all he had a quarter in
his hands and he had each one of us come
up and try to get the quarter from him
and we all completely failed and then he
said okay and they gave the quarter to
the one person in the class and said now
keeps a quarter away from me and the
person goes okay and she
tapped their hand I mean tackled them
and got the porter out of their hand in
two seconds and he goes you have to
fight and that is what a scene is about
you have to figure out what the quarter
is and you have to give that much energy
going for it after a decade in Hollywood
Anne Hathaway has transformed from
fairytale princess to force in the
industry and she's left a lasting
impression along the way this is
ineffable goodness Oh such a dream she's
so much fun she was my my rock on set we
were very we're like sparring buddies
she's great
and she's really funny and nice and
sweet and she's a great improviser and
hathaways somebody who will continue to
push yourself to striving to take on
Meteor roles I think she'll win an Oscar
at some point it's amazing to think you
know it doesn't feel like it's been a
decade but it has been you know some
people don't even get 10 years in this
industry and the idea that like it's
kind of coming together and I still get
to make amazing movies with inspiring
people and people are still kind of
curious about what I can do
it's I'm the luckiest girl in the world
that's incredible everyone knows what I
went through you know on this press tour
and it still is the most embarrassing
that the thing that's ever happened to
me is my experience with Daniel Craig so
I'm at this party and it's like a really
big party and it's my agency has thrown
it and I've only get it you're famous
okay no no I have to explain this
because it's the person I've ever gone
to one of these because there's this
party that CA throws before the Golden
Globes and I always thought it was a
cocktail party but it turns out if you
get to a certain level it's a dinner
party too and I was invited to the
dinner portion for the first time ever
so I'm sitting there and I'm just like
you know hobnobbing with all these
amazing actors and then like as the
party's transitioning into the the
cocktail portion Daniel Craig walks in
and there's not too many people there
unlike oh my god there's Daniel Craig
this is amazing he's just so beautiful
and all of his Emil it up and like looks
right at me and I'm like and then he
goes hey you I don't like I'm in my mind
this is how I retrofit the logic I was
like oh my god I have just instantly
become so famous that Daniel Craig is
messing with me and we don't even know
each other and so I'm like so of course
I'm like
and then he goes and he goes you and I
was like you and he's just like you
and I go oh I can't hear you mamita
important to mention that we're across
the room from each other so all this is
being done across a crowded room so I
just go you know I'm there and I start
to do some other things and then all of
a sudden Tania goes points behind me and
I turned around on the great British
director Stephen Daldry is there and
he's like now like doing inappropriate
things and I realize I'm just an idiot
and I just want to
what around me and this is why I
shouldn't be invited nice places
[Applause]
thank you guys so I can I hope you enjoy
they cast her vote on who you want to
see in the next top ten check out the
link in the description and go vote for
the person that you want me to profile
next I also want to give a quick sure to
make it locked in Meghan thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word doing the YouTube review
and post it on Twitter as well I really
really really appreciate support and I'm
so glad that you enjoyed it thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you hopefully to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
[Music]
I spoke to you and what seems like an
eternity ago at the lamia's
junket when I walked in the room myself
and other people were heaping praises on
you and you were kind of blushing and
you said that you're not used to this
kind of attention kind of used to being
the underdog are you now at the end of
this crazy
successful run of award season are you
willing to relinquish underdog status
officially officially never
I'm an actor man you always I mean this
is spectacular but if you want to get
realistic with it and thank you very
much for bringing it back down to earth
you're you know you're always looking
for the next job you always think at the
end of one it doesn't matter what's
happened before no one's ever gonna hire
me again so I do feel this evening the
respect of my peers and I'm gonna ride
that wave for as long as I can but I I
do also have a practical approach to
acting which is gotta work gotta work
gotta work